the indictments are not a surprise to me
Gayle King is breaking her silence on
our Kelly's recent arrest the singer was
taken into custody late last week on new
federal sex crime charges we've been
hearing that they are coming for quite
some time these are very serious charges
coming from federal officials I think
that it's a brand new ballgame so we
will see what happens and she credits a
lot of it to the power of media I think
that surviving art Kelly documentary was
a game changer and when you talk about
the power of media look at that
surviving art Kelly documentary it was
very well done
art Kelly of course insists that it's
all lies and it's not true but so many
women came forward and told their story
and after that documentary aired more
women came forward and told their story
and I think we are looking and hearing
things differently now than we used to
in the past and I don't think people are
these days given a pass or women are not
believed and I think that that has
changed so yeah the media makes a huge
difference on many stories and I think
the art Kelly stories is an example of
that of course King sat down with Kelly
earlier this year in an explosive
interview for CBS what I was worried
about is that he was he was flailing so
and hitting his fists so violently I was
worried that he would accidentally hit
me I've always believed that part of the
reason for his outburst meltdown
whatever you want to call it I think
that he was he's been aware of this
investigation and I think the stress of
that certainly I think has to play has
to mess with you and I think that might
have been part of the outbreak the 64
year old journalist also shared why she
thinks these charges may have been
ignored in the past we have heard these
charges in these stories about art Kelly
for years for years but I think many
people just gave him a pass because we
we liked his music so much and he had
been a trial and he had been acquitted
in the trial
so you think okay well he did go to
court and he was acquitted but now this
is is this these are different days in
different times and we're hearing things
with different ears King even revealed
that she contacted Kelly's reps after
his most recent arrest we all want to
know how is this going to play out I've
talked to our Kelly's representative
since he was arrested and they are still
very convinced that he will be fine and
that he will be proven innocent once
again they say they told me they're very
confident about that so we shall see